Speaker 1: So we had a call, maybe it
was last week, maybe the week before,
where a viewer asked me, what do I think happened
to the whole Matt Gates thing? The investigation
charges were expected, forthcoming, et cetera.
And I said, I don't know that these things can
take a while. I don't you know, I said at the
time, I don't know if Matt Gates is going to be
charged. It's not looking good, but I don't
know if Matt Gates is going to be charged.
The latest news is that Matt Gates has hired
a bevy of sex crime lawyers to defend him.
And it makes sense that if you expect
charges. Of murder, you would hire
lawyers who are experts in defending you against
murder charges, that sort of is logical, that
makes sense. And he's entitled to get lawyers. But
this is a sign of maybe the direction that things
are going best in writing for Vanity Fair, that
the last time we checked in on the legal comings
and goings of Matt Gates, things were not looking
great for him since the news broke this spring
that he was under investigation for paying women
for sex and separately for sleeping with a minor
and transporting her across state lines. The
hits have included Gates, his former wingman,
pleading guilty and having charges dropped
from three to six in exchange for cooperation.
That didn't look great for Gates. The news
that Gates had allegedly paid the women he
compensated through online payment platforms,
leaving a digital paper trail. Not good.
The news that the feds are additionally looking
into obstruction of justice charges. His former
wingman reportedly giving the feds years of Venmo
transactions and thousands of photos and videos.
And Gates being heckled on the street by strangers
shouting People think you're a pedophile.
Gates has denied allegations, but the latest news
in terms of his lawyers suggests that this could
be real trouble. Gates has hired a major team of
lawyers. The team, according to reporter Roger
Sullenberger, includes attorney Mark Mukasey, who
has defended the Trump organization in a number of
legal battles. Isabel Kershner, a top criminal
defense lawyer who represented Robert Hayden,
the ex Columbia University gynecologist accused
listen to this by 200 patients of sexual assault,
ultimately pleaded guilty with regard to two
patients, lost his medical license, didn't get
time in prison. So it seems that Isabel Kershner
is the right person to hire. Meanwhile, Gates's
campaign has returned. The service retained the
services of New York trial lawyer Marc Furnish,
who has the distinction of having defended
some of history's most notorious criminals,
including Jeffrey Epstein, the Mexican
drug lord Joaquin Guzman, a.k.a. El Chapo,
and Keith Raniere, who was sentenced to 120 years
in prison for running the next EVM sex cult,
where women were branded like physically
branded and forced into sexual slavery.
All of this suggests Gates is taking the
possibility of winding up in legal trouble very,
very seriously. Spokesperson for Gates declined
to declined a request for comment. So there's a
lot going on here. All right. In the context of
are there ever going to be charges, this signals
we should be keeping an eye on this because there
could be charges very, very soon and they could be
very serious charges. Now, here's my view on
the lawyer thing. If you ever need to defend
yourself for any crime you're accused of, whether
you're guilty or innocent doesn't matter whether
you're guilty or innocent. If you're accused of a
crime, you should hire a lawyer that specializes
in defending people against that type of
crime. Any sensible person would do that given
reasonable means so that Gates can hire whoever
he wants. This is a signal of what may be coming,
and that's it. If I were being criminally
tried, I would want a criminal lawyer.
If the criminal charges were murder, I would want
someone experienced in defending murder. There's
no question about it. The fact that he's hiring
these people signals that there are some really
serious charges potentially coming related to
sex crimes doesn't mean he's guilty. He gets his
day in court. Every time we talk about possible
charges, people write to me and they say, David,
do you not support due process? Do you not support
innocent until proven guilty? First of all,
sort of like do I support gravity? It's like
we have due process and people are innocent
until proven guilty. He gets his day in court.
Everybody's entitled to that. But this signals
that the charges may well be coming. However, he
really shouldn't be allowed to use campaign funds
for these lawyers because these are personal
charges. Now, there are people making the the
argument that part of this is retaining counsel
for his campaign so that if there are charges,
the campaign for reelection can continue
unfettered. It feels pretty weak to me.
The charges are for personal actions and he
should not be allowed to use campaign funds
for his defense. I feel very strongly about
that. There is already been reportedly twenty
five thousand dollars for a lawyer been paid by
the Gates campaign, even though the charges stem
from Gates alleged personal actions. That's
not good. That shouldn't be allowed. But
let's buckle up, because this really could
get very interesting very, very quickly.